Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
No,
it does seem like I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living tissue
suit is brought to you by 99 designs.
Your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world and here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world,
we'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim.
Yeah.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim,
that's athletic,
greens.com forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important,
it will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
So for me it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim.
Okay.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where I interview and
deconstruct world class performers to tease out all of the tactical actionable
bits that you can use,
the morning rituals,
the favorite books,
the meals,
the workouts,
the influences,
all of those things that you can replicate and pull into your own life.
This episode is chock full of all sorts of good information.
It was a lot of fun to do and there are two guests,
Stanley McChrystal and Chris Fussell.
Stanley McChrystal retired from the U s army as a four star general.
After more than 34 years of service.
Former defense secretary Robert Gates described him as quote,
perhaps the finest warrior and leader of men in combat I've ever met.
And quote from 2003 to 2008,
he served as commander of the Joint Special Operations Command,
otherwise known as Jay sock,
where he was credited with the death of Abu Musab al-Zarqawi leader of al Qaeda
in Iraq.
His last assignment was as commander of all American and coalition forces in
Afghanistan.
He's a senior fellow at Yale University's Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
and the cofounder of Cross lead a leadership consulting firm.
Chris Fussell is a former us navy seal officer,
also former aide,
the camp for general McChrystal.
And we'll get into what that means and a current senior executive at crosslead
and in this conversation,
which is very wide ranging and I think particularly important for people who are
anti military or uh,
have very strong feelings pro or con related to war to listen to.
We dig into,
of course,
some very personal habits and backgrounds.
So Stanley's,
we're very well known for eating one meal per day.
Why is that?
What does he eat?
We dig into it and workouts,
all of the very personal bits we dig into for both of these gentlemen.
And then we also talk about combat.
We talk about the realities of fear of death,
of combat,
of high stakes,
how to come back from a death in the field.
All of these things that I think have implications across many,
many disciplines including for the private sector quite frankly,
although the stakes are often lower.
So I hope you enjoy this interview.
There's a lot here.
There are a couple of areas where we get into a little bit of inside baseball,
uh,
related to special operations and things like that.
Please bear with me and go through it because there are gems hidden throughout,
I think from both of these gentlemen.
So hope you enjoy and thank you for listening.
Chris,
welcome to the show.
Thanks for having us.
Appreciate it.
Yeah,
I've been looking forward to this and have way more questions than we'll ever
get through today.
But I have been fascinated by not only the military and the training of the
military,
of the pros and cons of different aspects of the military,
but also how those translate to the civilian world.
And after the four hour body and the four hour chef has spent time with the
defense language institute and really become fascinated with the habits and
rituals of the top performers in that world.
So I have a slew of questions,
but the one that I have been asked to ask you stand more than perhaps any other
is why one meal a day?
Do you actually eat one meal a day?
I do.
Um,
and people ask me,
why is it some Zin connection with something?
And know what happened was when I was a lieutenant in special forces many,
many years ago,
I thought it was getting fat and I started running and started running distance,
which I enjoyed.
But I also found that my personality was such that I'm not real good at eating
three or four small discipline meals.
I'm better to defer gratification,
uh,
and then eat one meal.
And for me that's dinner.
And so what I do is I sort of pushed myself hard,
all dre try to get everything done and then and sort of reward myself with
dinner at night.
What time do you usually eat dinner?
Well,
whenever I'm finished work and uh,
it would be like eight or eight 30.
There's a challenge when you work really long hours because suddenly you start
to eat very late and then you go directly to bed and that,
that you feel like you're sleeping with a football and your stomach and do you
drink a coffee earlier in the day?
I'm just thinking with the workout and that many hours a lot of people would
would fade.
How do you prevent yourself from fading?
Yeah,
I have a tendency,
I'll drink coffee,
I'll drink other beverages to water and different things.
And I do find that there are certain days your body just says eat and eat right
now.
And I used to keep a bin of those hard pretzels in high office and Afghanistan
and I'd grab a handful of those.
And other times I might be out doing something physical in the military,
like road marching and suddenly your body communicates,
eat pretty quickly or you won't keep road marching and I'll,
and I'll do that.
But otherwise,
uh,
I like to stick to the idea of,
of one and I got it.
You know,
this is a,
this is a constant topic of conversation in the intermittent fasting worlds and
everyone has,
Ori Hofmekler has his thing.
The Paleo guys have,
have their thoughts obviously.
Are you a,
so you have one meal a day kind of guy?
Well,
when I was working for the general crystal as his aide to camp his last year
running the joint special operations command,
it was sort of a bite directive.
There was no other choice.
That was just the,
what we call the battle rhythm of the organization.
And when,
you know,
the old man got up to eat,
that's,
you did it then or you didn't do it at all.
Um,
so yeah,
I've,
I've lived on that terrain.
Um,
but I would be the first to tell others because,
um,
as,
as Dan alluded to,
it sort of became the driver in the organization.
But this is what we do.
And,
and I would tell people as his aide,
he won't judge you if you eat breakfast.
This is the way his metabolism works.
He doesn't do this as a,
as a demonstration of personal strength.
This is just what works.
So don't,
don't think you were impressing them by not eating lunch or whatever.
Um,
but there was a classic story around this.
When I first joined the inner circle staff,
um,
we had this,
uh,
command sergeant major,
who I'll call got,
uh,
a legend in the community.
He had been,
uh,
with Stan for about three and a half years at that point.
And so I was asking him about the one meal a day thing,
and he,
he said,
uh,
when he showed up for the first year,
he's,
you know,
two feet from stamp,
the entire five years they worked together.
And he said,
well,
this is what,
this is what the boss does.
This what I'll do.
So he did,
he did a meal a day and he does not have a metabolism that drives toward it.
And we lived in these little crummy Sorta quonset huts next to the,
uh,
where the headquarters was a quonset huts.
No,
just sort of wooden wooden huts.
Pretty Spartan living about 50 yards from where the headquarters was in Iraq.
And uh,
Jodi said about,
uh,
about a year into the tour that McChrystal cosmesis Jodie get in here.
So he runs over here.
What's up sir?
He goes,
and he,
he said,
I hadn't really looked through his hooch before and he said,
general McChrystal is pointing at these,
this little tin of pretzels he has.
And he goes,
I think there's my seat,
my pretzels.
And Jody said,
I almost whooped on my gun and shot him.
And I said,
you,
you've been eating pretzels.
I've been hitting my dark secret or a year.
And you had a friend souls in your room because it was the most unprofessional
I've ever been.
I just storm out of the room,
you know,
low blood sugar will do that.
Makes cowards of men long distance running and low blood sugar.
So you mentioned a hooch.
Now I,
so one of the challenges.